residents from the casket district bid a
warm welcome to employees from
transparency international
t.i nepal has been coming here since
2020 to combat corruption and protect
funds allocated to fight climate change
the central government allocates a
budget to climate change
yet just 20 of those funds actually wind
up where they're supposed to
that's what we discovered in our
investigation
instead of going towards climate change
the money is often used for meetings or
seminars with
and that needs to change t.i nepal
regularly asks residents of caskey how
climate change is affecting them
often the local authorities aren't even
aware of their problems
so the information that's gathered here
is sent to them too
that helps lend a voice to people who've
previously gone unheard and gives them
the courage to advocate for themselves
compared to men we women are often less
well-educated we've started to address
the negative consequences of corruption
as well as the effects of a lack of
transparency
we've become far more interested in
these issues as a result
[Music]
the forest is vital to the people of
caskey
it provides them with firewood and food
for their animals
but now their very livelihood is at risk
[Music]
there's been a huge landslide on the
other side of the valley
and it's not the only landslide that's
happened in the region
normally the snow-covered annapurna
mountains would be visible but they're
shrouded in clouds
the monsoons have changed bringing
longer and heavier spells of rain
look here everything is still soaked
from the rain it's been like this for 12
days
even my house was flooded
half the grain is ruined
it should have been harvested long ago
many here don't understand the cause of
their growing problems
and believe they're being punished by
the gods
we've seen that people don't have any
idea about climate change and even ti
and nepal when we are starting from
scratch and we are finding it so
difficult
to make people understand what's climate
change what's the environment you know
impact
[Music]
that's why the ngo asked public
broadcaster radio nepal for help
it's produced ads that raise awareness
about climate change
torrential rains have also destroyed
crops in the chitwan district in the
south of the country
the farmers try to salvage what they can
the downpours have also caused the water
levels of both rivers here to rise
the rivers flood their banks several
times a year often sweeping away homes
and farmland
yet instead of shoring up riverbanks
local authorities often spend climate
change funds on roads
the local government hasn't been able to
develop plans and strategies to tackle
these problems
so the population suffers
people cannot even supply themselves
with the bare essentials
the fishes are suffering too
rising temperatures cause the rivers to
dry up in the summer
water quality has also deteriorated
rapidly
look here
i didn't catch a single fish
before i could cast my net and get 15 or
20 of them
with a single throw
but there's reason to hope the situation
will improve soon
staff from transparency international
are working closely with the authorities
to determine why funding doesn't end up
where it's so badly needed
and the local government has promised to
allocate more money for victims of
climate change
and for protective measures to combat
flooding such as buffer zones
in every sector each of us have played a
small small roles in adding up to the
corruption it's not only like keeping
the money in your pocket or you it's not
only money laundering but it's also
about when you don't really do your duty
when you don't really like you know know
it to how to know to how to do your duty
then also it it adds up to the
corruption so yeah
people affected by climate change can
also take action
transparency international helps them
obtain the funds that have been
allocated to them
it's an important step
on the long road to change
you